is Fred Andrews alive what was up with
that steamy shower sex and which season
one character made a shocking return all
that and more on this week's episode of
Sweetwater secrets hey everyone I'm your
host Liana Galera and first and foremost
if you have not watched Riverdale season
2 premiere chapter 14 a kiss before
dying dunk dunk done you need to leave
right now because we are about to spoil
everything that happened and this was
such an amazing episode plus I'm gonna
be bringing you exclusive content from
Cole Sprouse KJ Appa and Camilla Mendes
because I was just up in Vancouver on
the Riverdale set and they gave me so
many behind-the-scenes secrets about
tonight's episode but first and foremost
hit the comments right now tell me what
your favorite part of the episode was or
tweet me and we will be discussing all
this stuff because sweetwater Secrets is
your go-to source to freak out over all
things Riverdale alright guys now we're
gonna kick things off with the top
headlines of the night and this week's
blue-and-gold breakdown top headline of
the night you guys Fred Andrews is alive
yes Thank You TV gods for saving the
hottest DILF on TV so we did get to see
that Fred survived it was a little
touch-and-go there for a while but we
got some truly heartwarming
flash-forwards - what Archie's life
might become and I've got to say
Veronica you look fantastic in a wedding
dress girl loving it this episode I was
just so excited that we got to see that
Fred survived because I think that
Archie and Fred's father-son dynamic is
one of the best parts of Riverdale and
it's something that I would like to see
a lot more from in season two so praise
be he's okay now the other top headline
of the night oh hi miss Grundy it's not
so nice to see you again yes my least
favorite character in Riverdale history
made a shocking return in tonight's
episode now a cross Sweetwater River she
was in another town giving music lessons
to other teen boys out there and yes she
is still preying on their innocence girl
date someone your own age it's creepy
now just as we were all getting so upset
that she was kissing yet another
teenager yet we saw that the
figure yes the exact same one that shot
Fred Andrews in the season 1 finale came
in through the window and he killed miss
Grundy to make matters even more
shocking he killed her using the cellos
both at Archie gave her in season 1 ah
how crazy is that
it's totally fitting though and I gotta
say sorry not sorry I miss Grundy glad
you're gone don't hate me but you can't
or actually don't haunt me mmm all right
moving on guys this episode was filled
with one of the steamiest scenes in
Riverdale history yes that's right I'm
talking about the VAR cheese shower sex
and it is our top moment in tonight's 7
seconds in heaven
[Music]
oh my gosh I did not know that they were
gonna go there but hey it is a CW show
and hey it is a really attractive couple
so I'm not mad at it and I know you guys
aren't mad at it either so I have a
little treat for you when I was up on
the Riverdale set in Vancouver I caught
up with Cammie and KJ about what it took
to film that shower scene and let's just
say things got a little slippery let's
take a look we gotta talk about that
steamy scene in Episode one oh yes when
you read in this grip rgm Veronica we're
going to be having shower sexy times
what was your reaction I was wasn't I
surprised yeah I mean we are constantly
doing things by that we're closely doing
things I knew that way before I read the
script
Roberto or showrunner had told me
there's gonna be like a really steamy
scene and I was like okay I'll get ready
I've got a month to physically prepare
myself no but it was it was really fun
it's kind of funny playing a scene like
that I'm having a whole camera crew like
right around here does a man in the
bathroom standing there Adam Adam how
might Adam who does the effects was
standing there with the long I think
every time we came out of the thing he'd
stand against the wall like this
and we were just cracking out laughing
because nothing we're allowed to look at
us with yeah yeah but KJ always makes it
so funny that it's it's a blast did you
guys have any like onset like slippery
moments kind of I you know i how always
had to like keep my girl it was pretty
slippery Nate I had a fog machine in the
actual bathtub what's harder though is
making out in the water like and you
just we wanted to spit it all out but we
had a makeout so just like the funniest
those two are the absolute sweetest and
we had so much fun together on set get
ready for even more scoop from the cast
now I've got to give a quick shout out
to Betty and Jughead because their kiss
by the rain was oh so sweet in tonight's
episode
but now guys it is time to move on to my
favorite segment of the night he
and kisses starting off with hisses now
these are the moments that kind of
bugged me in tonight's episode so bear
with me a little bit
so first up when you invite the lovely
Molly Ringwald back to Riverdale here's
my thought
get her a line sidenote who else thought
it was interesting that in the wedding
fantasy scene that Mary Andrews was
sitting with the rest of the blosum
family now this is a theory that I've
been working on for a while I think that
Mary Andrews is somehow tied to the
blosum family and no that's not just
because they all have the same gorgeous
red hair I really think that there's a
secret there that we will be exploring
in season two and I'm gonna get to the
bottom of it
my next hiss of the night is to the
lodge women Veronica and Hermione ladies
what is going on you guys were such a
dynamic force in season one what is with
all this tension I understand that with
the introduction of Hyrum back into the
family that things are gonna be shaken
up a little bit but I really did not
care to see these two strong women
butting heads so much at each other you
guys get it together now as for
tonight's kisses yes that one is
straight to you Mark Consuelos welcome
to the Riverdale family and I gotta say
we barely saw you in this episode do you
make a truly terrifying Hyrum Lodge not
so much that I still don't want to kiss
a little for my daughter
next up got to give a major kiss out to
my girl Mads because psychotic Cheryl is
the best thing ever I am here for your
delicious vicious monologue to your mama
honey things are going to be different
now mommy
better also really enjoyed that random
kiss of life that you gave to Fred
Andrews if you're gonna get a kiss from
a blossom girl might as well be Cheryl
and my last mwah kiss tonight is to the
fact that jugheads got a brand new ride
who else loved seeing that introduction
of the motorcycle in tonight's episode I
know I sure did so when I caught up with
Cole Sprouse
on set of course I had to ask him about
it had you already known how to ride a
motorcycle yeah yeah yeah I used to ride
models when I was you
like dirt bikes and then as I got older
my dad's a big model rider so I got my
license and when I found out he was
riding a motorcycle on the show my
little Disney self quivered because wow
he can be cool Matt - I think I talked
to my Disney self as like like a
whatever 11 year old he'd be like no way
are people buying this no way is this
working probably pretty often only in my
nightmares now yeah but it's cool I mean
it's
it's an old moto so it's a little
rickety
yeah they don't let me on on it too much
because it's definitely a stunt hazard
it feels very classic Americana and
that's it's a classic cafe racer so it
feels like super old-school and an
awesome touch with that crown on the
helmet yeah love that little carving
yeah that was the props touch very well
done
I really liked it Oh Cole keep talking
to your Disney self and then keep
telling me about it alright guys looking
ahead to next week's episode which is
called chapter 15 Nighthawks I can tease
that we're going to be diving even
deeper into Archie's psyche as he's
trying to deal with the repercussions of
Fred being alive but you know there's
still a shooter out on the loose and I'm
gonna be bringing you exclusive scoop
from Ashley Marie all about what's up
next for the Pussycats in season 2 plus
Lily Reinhardt is gonna be filling me in
on bug heads future and you definitely
don't want to miss that alright guys
that does it for this week's episode of
Sweetwater secrets once again hit the
comments or chat with me on Twitter
about your top hisses and kisses of the
night and I will see you next time for
even more Riverdale goodness
[Music]
you